so if you're advising a screenwriter
who's starting out day one on their
project to come up with a character it
is that one of the first tips you're
giving them is this relational core not
a probably an on day one day one you
would start with obviously the idea
what's your concept so I think concept
is important once you know your concept
and there's ways to make that concept
appealing the class I'm teaching
tomorrow morning will be on concept how
to make sure your concept is high and by
high concept I don't know there's a
there's a term for AI concept in
Hollywood but for me it means that there
is high appeal meaning that as soon as
you had the idea you go oh there's
something about it that just like hooks
you and you go wow I want to find out
what it's about or how it's resolved so
that's what you should at first the next
thing that you should think about for me
and I know there's controversy about
that whether you do that first or later
for me I need to know what it's about
you know was what I meant this whole
story will be a reflection of what
you're trying to say like what's your
theme what's the meaning of your story
and if you don't know what it is well
you could try developing a story and
write many drafts and then and then you
figure out what it is you know okay
that's possible a lot of writers do that
and that's okay but I always use Paddy
Chayefsky z' quote which says lucky is
the writer who knows its name from the
beginning because once you know that you
you've got I always suggest you write it
in big letters and put it in front of
your computer so you see it at all times
because most of your characters most so
you've seen your whole story will be a
reflection of what you're trying to sell
your theme and so it's better to know it
right away it'll save you a lot of time
from trying to write many drafts and
then come back to it and cut what
doesn't work and create you know new
things but if you know themes so so for
me it's concept then theme and then once
you know your theme then you can create
your characters because your character
will be a reflection especially if your
character has an arc will be a
reflection of that theme and so you know
where your character is going to start
and now you know where character is
gonna end and then you can figure out
your scenes and your story in terms of
all the stuff I'm talking about
character connection and motivational
and stuff those are details that you can
add
later but what I'm talking about is what
the foundation of stories which is what
is your story about and how does your
character transform to reflect that
theme that you're trying to convey and
yeah that's the foundation
you